in this video we're going to be covering
a step-by-step plan for how to make four
thousand dollars in the next four months
and actually this is coming out of my
personal experience a few years ago when
I was living in a thousand square foot
apartment with my wife Sonia in Southern
California I started making a particular
type of videos that helped my family
earn extra money while I was working a
full-time job in fact I even earned
thousands of dollars talking about
coffee pods and I'm going to describe
that strategy in this video and so we're
talking about how to earn four thousand
dollars in the next four months with a
simple YouTube strategy you know fast
forward to today and I've grown multiple
YouTube channels to over a hundred
thousand subscribers I actually just got
another silver play button ordered just
yesterday and then of course our main
Channel think media is 2.3 million or
something like that but here's the
YouTube strategy and our goal today is
to create and rank YouTube videos
optimized to earn money with a affiliate
marketing in preparation for the holiday
shopping season so no matter what time
of the year you're watching this video
this this will be valuable you can do it
at any time but if you happen to be
watching this live at this moment or on
the replay this is a very strategic
moment to get focused to cut out
distractions and to go all in on YouTube
because we're in a countdown to the
fourth quarter of the year and the
holiday shopping season which ultimately
becomes a massive money making
opportunity so let me tell you the
strategy again we're going to create and
rank YouTube videos they're going to be
optimized in a particular way optimized
to earn money with affiliate marketing
there's multiple ways to earn money on
YouTube that's one way and that's what
we're going to do in our strategy today
in preparation for the holiday shopping
season so it's important that we take
action now and we dive in so smash the
like button and uh we're going to give
you four tips today and this is also the
coffee with Channel show so you can
check out check out time code and
chapters because just during the first
portion we have a training then I do
some live coaching with a guest and then
I'll also be answering some q a so take
advantage of the time codes and chapters
as we dive into things and so let's get
into number one create YouTube videos
intentionally optimized to earn money
with affiliate marketing this is a big
key one of the reasons people struggle
to earn money with affiliate marketing
is they just throw some random links in
their description they make some random
video but the whole thing is not
strategic so the key is you want to
start with the end in mind and you want
to create videos intentionally designed
and optimized to earn money with
affiliate marketing here's two questions
what are people searching for and what
are people buying online
what are people searching for on Google
on YouTube and what are people buying
online this month later and what will
they be buying every month like they'll
always be buying PlayStation fives and
the price just dropped and they will
also be buying them this holiday
shopping season
they'll always be buying what fill in
the blank now what you'll notice here is
that we are talking about making videos
that are related to products and maybe
reviewing or giving a comparison and the
cool thing is that really any channel
can do this I know if you're like
entertainment or something else you
might not see how it fits I'm not saying
you have to make your whole Channel like
a product review Channel or something
you're you're trying to pick out
something that people are searching for
that people are buying online but also
that relates to your channel of course
um for me here's some examples that I've
done over the years and if you look at
the date on these videos 10 years ago I
made a video called gift ideas for him
and a couple of these gift ideas for
Creative people gift ideas for men this
is kind of like an obvious holiday
shopping type of a video people are
looking for gift ideas they're searching
for it and then they're buying stuff and
this is literal like they're buying
gifts but there's other ways I did it
where I actually covered Christmas laser
lights I spotted a trend six years ago
at my Smith's grocery store in Las Vegas
as soon as something started showing up
kind of to be the mainstream I was like
man people are going to be searching for
this online as well and wanting to order
these really ugly Christmas laser lights
that project on your house for the lazy
people that don't want to take the time
to put up their Christmas laser lights
like crusts or their normal lights like
Clark Griswold in National Lampoon's
Christmas Vacation you know if you're
lazy like me you just want to project
the ugliest whatever so ultimately this
video earned thousands of dollars
um and in multiple ways and I'll be
explaining that in a second uh but it's
another type of a strategic video now
this is also a channel that you're like
Sean why are you talking about gifts for
you know people that has nothing to do
with your think media channel it's a
good point this was a separate Channel
that I did a lot of experiments on that
actually didn't have the best branding
it was a little more random but
nevertheless it actually still generated
a lot of money
another example is you think about like
just best books best books for your
topic best books no matter what it is
cooking you know personal development
Science History and in this case I did
best self-improvement books now people
will be searching for this all year
round this also is going to do a lot
better in January so so forget just
getting ready for December
you start preparing now for January
because
um it's New Year New You people are
looking for particular topics they want
to lose weight they want to get their
mind right they want to start something
new so actually it's not just the next
four months we really could be talking
about the next five months if you're
really strategic and then it also might
be something that's just like I've done
this is more related right to my main
think media channel the Yi 4K action
camera
um it's just a camera that people are
searching for this was a budget action
camera and also kind of fun because I
take it uh snowboarding I'd have to go
test and you know of course you got to
consult your CPA but when you are going
up snowboarding and buying your lift
tickets and buying your meal that's no
longer a recreational trip that's a
business trip because it's ordinary and
necessary that I actually have to go
um you know test this camera out and
create content for my YouTube channel a
whole separate conversation about why
everybody should uh start a side hustle
or a side business YouTube business
because the tax advantages that you
could have but I'm not a CPA so check
that out for yourself and this was also
the coffee story like this was me
um nine years ago when we were in our
apartment and I was able to make a video
talking about certain pods that were
non-starbucksburizmo pods that works in
a very small machine it seems really
random and Niche but here's the deal
we're talking about how to make four
thousand dollars in the next four months
I'm gonna get more Tactical for you in a
second but this stuff works when you
learn the skill set and when you make
the right videos and if you had a
Cooking Channel or you had some kind of
a you know Food Channel this would be
more on brand and it could be a
win-win-win-win-win in terms of
um ultimately earning money growing your
Channel all that kind of stuff now this
is coffee with candle so I've got four
more tips three more tips for you but we
are only
um I I can't go fully into this strategy
and just last night I recorded a brand
new free training and it's it's actually
a little over an hour long and there's
even more q a so I do want you to take
advantage of that if you're interested
in going deeper and like it's really how
to do this that's at uh
freethinkclass.com and I break down
exactly how I turned 130 dollars into
over twenty thousand with a single
YouTube video this class is On Demand
right now and there's a link in the
description and you can totally check
that out if you don't want to okay cool
no worries but uh that will be valuable
if you I'm sure you have a lot of
questions about this and I do have my
coaching guest coming on in a second so
we're gonna land the plane with a few
more tips here so tip number two you're
gonna create one video per week for the
next 18 weeks so if you're gonna get if
you're actually going to make money on
YouTube over the next four months you
actually have to upload videos to
YouTube
you could tweet that
you can X that
is that what it's called now are we
tweeting are we Xing or what are we
doing
um I know that's kind of dumb but like
if you want to build a financial
momentum
if you're making these strategic
optimized intentional videos make one a
week for the next 18 weeks now imagine
you did two videos a week that's gonna
be you know 36 videos so you could get
36 videos published between now and the
end of the year if you did two videos a
week the more momentum you create the
more uploads and not just random uploads
they gotta be strategic uploads
intentionally optimized videos
researched topics especially if you want
to earn money with affiliate marketing
optimize to earn money with affiliate
marketing right and so um
that is going to be a huge key but this
would be our plan for how to do this
over the next how to earn four thousand
in the next four months number three set
realistic expectations and put in the
work
so a couple things to sort of Show an
example personally and now this is a
modern example April 1st to June 30th
I looked at just our top five Amazon
affiliate earning products I have a tech
Channel and if you looked at the top
five products there's actually more than
five videos because we've done a lot of
videos about the zve E10 probably only
like one or two about the sigma 16. the
q9u broadcast microphone that's only one
video I'm pretty sure
um the bi-color LED gvm light I think
that's one video the mount dog video is
for sure one video and it totaled in
three months time
6133 dollars this is that's the Amazon
affiliate commissions from YouTube
videos connected to affiliate marketing
now you might be saying well Sean I mean
easy for you to say bro I mean and also
you're posting that on a channel that's
got all these subscribers and I'm just
starting well fair enough
so I want you to set realistic
expectations and here's a prediction I
could make you know if you do this and
you go all in how much you're gonna make
in the first month my guess is zero how
much are you gonna make in the second
month also maybe zero but how much could
you make in the third month maybe 500 to
a thousand dollars and how much could
you make in the fourth month especially
if it's around Black Friday Cyber Monday
and holiday shopping
uh maybe a couple thousand dollars and
then roll that over into January so if
you end up making
three thousand three hundred dollars in
the next six months would you be okay
with that I mean it's there's a spectrum
to this uh and I think that the key is
it has a lot of factors are you talking
about more expensive Tech are you
talking about lipstick are you talking
about but here's the math and so let's
do the math you know if you could
generate a hundred thousand dollars in
commissions or in sales now keep in mind
that's not you don't get a hundred
thousand dollars that's like a hundred
thousand dollars of whatever you're
recommending as an affiliate a hundred
thousand dollars worth of yoga supplies
a hundred thousand dollars worth of
cameras a hundred thousand dollars worth
of um pan you know food for prepper
Pantry hundred thousand dollars of
preparedness stuff
you know paracord uh compasses hunting
gear fishing supplies so whatever
and assuming the commission is four
percent it could be a lot of different
percentages
different websites have different
percentages I just know that Amazon pays
me four percent for Tech so if you could
do a hundred thousand dollars
over four months so again if it's a
little bit lighter in the first few
months because it takes time to build up
the momentum
but just total oversimplifying the math
you do a hundred thousand dollars Top
Line That's how much like transactions
happen you get a four percent commission
you get paid four thousand dollars
so
if you make a four month plan and put in
the work and learn the skills and have
this and put the whole strategy together
that's just exactly how you could do it
now mind you I'm not I'm not saying any
YouTube ad Revenue in this conversation
this is purely affiliate marketing you
don't even have to do Amazon there's
lots of different websites like you
could sign up for Dick Sporting Goods or
bat brass Bass Pro Shop do a hundred
thousand dollars worth of orange vests
you know Bass Pro Shop hats just in
terms of the videos you create the
amount of times your links get clicked
the amount of things that are purchased
and here's also why now is the time to
go all in with this particular strategy
you know e-commerce is really blowing up
and as of right now this might surprise
you
um only
one out of five people
are really making their retail purchases
online
28.8 percent of retail purchases are
expected to take uh to take place online
in 2023. maybe another way to frame that
stat is this there's actually about 76
percent of U.S adults shop online but
the total amount of retail purchases
this year
only one out of five purchases are
happening online total and the rest are
happening in stores but here's what's
happening the number keeps going up and
so the reason I share this with you is
e-commerce is online shopping and you
have the chance to create strategic
YouTube content related to affiliate
marketing which means you get a piece of
that online shopping pie but this is why
it's not too late to get started with
this strategy because more people are
coming online that have not been online
before more people are coming online
that want to start their Crab Pot
Journey like my friend Anthony bought
crab pots to shop in the Pacific
Northwest to to fish do you fish for
crabs what do you do scrape for crabs to
put the pots the crab traps in the ocean
to get his crabs whatever so so more
people are like they're searching for
something specific hobby RC cars all
these different hobbies and this is how
you can cash in on your passion on
YouTube but by 2026 24 of retail
purchase purchasing are expected to take
place online so this conversation is a
lot bigger than just let's make four
thousand dollars in the next four months
this is if you commit to the strategy
put in the work learn the skills put out
a lot of quality videos and I don't mean
quality like fancy lighting I mean good
information and that serve and help
people
and then you rank those videos over the
next multiple years the amount of money
that is in the system is staggering and
you could get a piece of that to be
exactly specific uh it's actually 6.3
trillion dollars is the global email
Commerce Market
um as of 2023 is how big it is globally
6.3 trillion with the T and over the
next four months here's what also
happens is when you strategically make
videos at strategic times meaning like
in preparation for Q4
I've learned that my affiliate
commissions over the years when I was
doing this as a side hustle I'd be
making like one or two hundred dollars a
month as an affiliate and then in
November and December it would go to a
thousand it would 5X
so you getting prepared now is a big
deal and so fortune favors the bold and
fortune favors those who take action and
so if you put in the work put in the
action start posting videos and if you
post one video a week for the next 18
weeks or two videos a week for the next
18 weeks the other key is will all of
them succeed to make money no some will
make no money but a lot of times one or
two or three of them will be the ones
that earn all of the revenue basically
because one kind of Pops off and you
didn't really expect that thing to
really work and then a lot of people
click the link and they make other
purchases and so check this out though
this is really wild
is if we just use the four percent
number
if it's a 6.3 trillion dollar
opportunity four percent meaning if
smart strategic online creators like you
were making videos that were serving
people in Thailand on the pros and cons
of products or comparing two products or
helping people with products
that is too
252 billion dollars paid to Affiliates
if you were just earning four percent
and that's kind of an arbitrary number
because in some cases you earn 10 or 20
or even 50 on some transactions and then
sometimes Amazon pays like one percent
on groceries but I think that I want you
to see the real math no hype that's like
that is the pool that you can tap into
do you understand how big of a number
that is and then you start saying oh
okay well I could make 50k a year
working from home doing this if I got
positioned properly in the crater
economy I could make a six-figure income
because I just need a piece of that and
we're not even talking about brand deals
ad revenue or anything else this is
actually just getting a piece of the
e-commerce sales that's only happening
this year
is the 6.3 trillion and next year it
goes up to like seven something and next
year goes up to eight so we're there's a
wave right now there's a movement right
now and and the key is to get position
to be strategic number four
um this is a big deal if the product has
a higher price point you get a bigger
part of the sale
and you get a bigger part of the sale
you'll make money quicker
so
I happen to talk about cameras tech I
get four percent
and the good thing about that stuff
though is it does have a higher price
point different than talking about a ten
dollar lipstick and getting four percent
of that right that's gonna be what 40
cents versus four percent of a thousand
is forty dollars so somebody buys a
thousand dollar camera I get forty
dollars that adds up pretty quick you
know sell three of those a day you make
120 in a day it's pretty cool
but here's the other key
if you get a bigger part of the sale I
mean a higher percentage
and so if you want to make four thousand
dollars in the next four months the
types of affiliate programs you choose
the types of products you choose the way
you position even your brand or your
Channel or the content you're creating
if you're thoughtful about the whole
thing the money the financial
opportunity is massive and I'll give you
one case study as we land the plane
so seven years ago I made a video about
a greens juice powder called organifi
that I personally Love by the way if
you're like is this some kind of weird
scam is this like a pyramid scheme
affiliate marketing done right is a
win-win-win-win-win you share products
you personally love and use that you
would recommend to friends and family
that you've tested that you've had an
experience with you share valuable
information about why people would enjoy
or the pros and the cons and if it's
right for this person or not or even
products they should avoid so it's a win
for the person that's shopping because
they get to hear from you not the brand
they get to hear from somebody who's
ethical in the middle that can help them
just learn about products but then the
brand wins as well too the creator of
the product because they generate more
sales they give you a piece of the
commission it doesn't make the product
cost more money
and I know there are like scammy
marketers and scammy affiliate marketers
but that's not you you wouldn't be a
part of our purpose-driven community if
that was you and so ultimately the cool
thing is that uh this was a product that
first I used I like to travel stay
healthy drink green juice I can mix with
water in hotel rooms when I was
traveling as a videographer and all this
other stuff well here's what's wild
about this product the commissions are
not four percent
they're 30 percent
and an additional tip you also get
what's called continuity
so if somebody subscribed to say hey
mail me a bottle or organify every
single month
if that person stuck with organifi for
one two three years I got 30 on every
single order for the next three years
compounding
not one percent ten percent or five
percent thirty percent so that is
actually why this one video hasn't
earned
20 over twenty thousand dollars about
two thousand dollars in ad Revenue but
about eighteen thousand dollars in
product sales by the way that's over
seven years and that's we can't even we
don't have time to get into the power of
ranking videos but this is how you could
create videos they bring in passive
income and the money can keep coming in
and also now's a really good time to
position yourself to think about how to
strategically do this around the
holidays and so again if you could get
higher price point
and a higher percentage and things like
continuity things can get really
interesting so if you want to go a
little bit deeper on this uh right now
this class is on demand you can go to
freethinkclass.com this training is
available for a limited time I get I go
even deeper it's about two total hours
when we talk about q a and everything
there's a link to this in the
description down below and actually
Melissa from uh the think media team and
I also talk about
um a way to go like to have different
products we talk about one example where
you could get like 50 commissions on
like a thousand dollar product and then
you would only need what eight of those
and you would make four thousand dollars
if you did like eight transactions so
when you start to unpack the math things
can get really interesting and you can
reach your financial goals faster now if
you have any questions fire me off a
question
um in with three question marks before
and after the question we do have a
guest and we're gonna dive in right now
to our guest in just a second but I do
want to welcome you to the coffee with
Channel show and
today we are excited to be here coming
to you from the Pacific Northwest and uh
we're gonna dive in with our guest
right now
[Music]
foreign
show my name is Sean Cannell rhymes with
YouTube channel and I am fired up today
because one of the things that we do is
we do some coaching with some of our
video Reiki Academy students
um and we come on we do some Channel
reviews we go through their questions
I'm pulling up all that information
right now today we have joy Joe Avella
and he'll tell us all about his Channel
Once on position and ready here
um and then after this segment make sure
to check out time codes and chapters
because we'll also be getting into any
questions you have about today's topic
or anything else and smash like if
you're already getting value today Joe
welcome to the show hi Sean thanks for
having me can you guys hear me oh man
you sound great Studio looks great air
pods we got the same mic you got artwork
behind you
how you feeling
uh feeling great thanks for uh taking
the time to chat with me today on your
show I really appreciate it
um I I am so grateful you're here and
I'm actually going to pull up your
channel and I love it if you told us a
little bit about uh how long you've been
creating content what is it you are up
to and what are you doing on your
channel uh so I've been creating the
type of content that is on my channel
probably for the past two years for the
past eight years I've been a video
producer with food insiders so food and
travel snacks International stuff is
primarily the focus of uh my channel and
it's a bit of an extension of what I do
for work at Food Insider which is uh
food and travel reviews
uh let's see here what was the other
question I'm sorry so do you still work
at Food Insider yes I do and then you
also have your own channel correct
separate
yes completely separate from the idea
has been for the past two years as much
as I enjoy my job uh I do love doing
other things that don't fall into what I
could do with food Insider so I decided
to
do that stuff on my own channel uh and
it has been a mixed bag of results to
say the least I'm kind of throwing
everything that I'm learning at it
and uh I don't know kind of like uh feel
like I've been spinning my wheels the
past few months so I wanted to uh come
in here and uh figure out what uh what
you think is a a good strategy I love it
so we're 22 000 subscribers 406 videos
and we've had 1.2 million views on the
channel and
um tell me a little bit about maybe a
specific question that you have great so
as I mentioned before uh food Insider
I've been and a producer and an on uh
Camera Host with them for several years
now and the shows I do there are pretty
Popular by my standards a lot of the
videos get millions of views and I feel
like I've cultivated a fan base that
I've been trying to direct to my channel
and with that I've been trying to figure
out ways that I can make work for that
fan base that's more specific to what I
want to do versus what I do with my
employer and I'm not quite sure exactly
how to go about doing that I've dabbled
with a few things here or there and I
feel like I've just been spinning my
wheels so as someone who does have like
a successful YouTube uh presence
elsewhere what do you think would be a
way to not only point my fan base in
that direction uh but also once I have
them on YouTube channel figuring out
shows or things that I could do that are
kind of on brand
yeah it's great so on the one hand
you uh let me ask you a few more
questions what have you learned about
some of your top performing videos
what did I learn about my top performing
videos well it seems like if I could
find that sweet spot so show I do that
is really popular uh compares the US and
the UK and I thought like why don't I if
I position myself as an American who's
trying stuff from the UK and I've tried
some other countries you can see at the
bottom right there Japanese snacks if I
can try things that are not inherently
American and these American trying them
for the first time I feel like people
are interested in that and I'm
interested in making content like that
um and trying a lot of things and
talking about them over the Long Haul
has really helped with my average watch
time and uh with having videos that are
over you know like eight or nine minutes
long also financially those videos do
better with several ad breaks
but it's that sweet spot of finding me
as an American wanting to experience
things that the other world has to offer
that I could bring to my home that isn't
too expensive in the sense of like
shipping or obviously traveling
um that I guess
that's what I'm looking for that sweet
spot of like guy tries and enjoys things
from blank but isn't um you know
financially right now I can't hop on a
plane and go to Spain and you know try
the pizza there or whatever you know
what I mean yeah that's my next question
is what's your workflow are you kind of
do you have to film and edit these
things yourself are you trying to invest
a little bit of money into building up
your own brand so I want to invest in
building my own brand right now I'm
doing everything myself which is another
reason why I feel like the bottleneck is
doing stuff that I can Finance not only
financially do but also outside of my
nine to five uh workflow because I'm a
full-time employee so it's uh
time is a little um
scarce I guess and also money is money
scarce
yeah
uh it's not like scare scarce but it's
like I would like to not
um I would like to take everything I
earned from the YouTube channel and kind
of invest it back into the stuff that
I'm making and right now the channel is
yielding like with ad Revenue like
70 80 bucks a month ooh okay what's your
RPM
uh I don't know how do I let me see her
uh
yeah so if you go into your
um analytics and you go into YouTube
Studio
Analytics
Revenue scroll down videos it'll say
Revenue per thousand views think media
is 753 right now and then shorts is
seven cents seven seven cents per
thousand views unless I'm at the revenue
and then what do I do so you go to
revenue and then just scroll down a
little bit and it says content
performance
on the right side
and
um you can you can segment it here it is
content performance so uh oh so ah three
dollars and twenty cents for video yeah
great that's that's good it's pretty
it's uh solid not even really low it's a
good average RPM what's nice about that
and why our community watching this show
is it's it's nice to do the math that
that number can fluctuate but if you
just start you could set you could start
setting some goals and even maybe write
those on a note card and post it on your
mirror or whatever but you're like okay
so if I can start getting a million
views a month if those views are
monetized
um that would be three thousand dollars
a month
and so you're at 31 000 views right now
but then that starts being you you put
out a couple of back to back you know
bangers or uh if you could do the
obviously you're like well yeah exactly
but if I could get 100 000 views and do
10 of these a month then you're at three
grand so it's just kind of like an
interesting way to think about it you
know where I go is
um I think this will be kind of fun to
get tactical and uh speaking about you
know in video ranking Academy
um we talk about the seminars as you
know have you been through the whole
thing uh not yet no so uh we go research
We Go reverse engineer and then research
and so for me
you I'll share with you like and I think
this would be really fun for the rest of
our community
um seven different ways to research and
come up with ideas for your channel and
so the first one is audience research
and I'll give you a few ideas on each of
these you could go to your community Tab
and say hey guys what are you wanting
most you know what
um you you look in your comments what
are people asking for more of do a part
two of that oh please do this food so it
takes the time because what you're
looking for is you're looking for 100
000 view video ideas because we could
get 10 100 000 view video ideas we could
um get a million views a month and of
course some of those you're going to get
a lot better you might get a quarter
million views and million view video
ideas but we're looking for audiences as
one of the sources then of course
keyword research and that is is really
great because there may be a particular
type of
food
um I also really think you should go all
in on verses like this chocolate bar
versus that chocolate bar or you stack
up like seven things I've seen that some
of the best channels in all kinds of
niches will go like I saw this actually
with healthy chocolate so there's this
whole movement on uh like Whole Foods of
like it's the good sugar and no GMO or
no bad ingredients but they were like
there was like 10 as many as could fit
in the title it was kind of a little too
long but they they compared like the
five of the biggest things as kind of a
showdown I think there's an opportunity
for you you could have it even viewed
out you're like I'm gonna compare these
five sodas or these five countries or
these five you know we just learned from
Mr Beast
um that he's smart and a genius on so
many levels but one of the most genius
things about his most recent video was
the idea of getting all the countries of
the world competing against each other
in his own Olympics and one of the
wisdom of that was not just the
spectacle of the video and how
entertainment how entertaining it was
and the challenge the scaling challenge
but it was the culture hacking quite
literally like a type it tapping into
different cultures because now you're
enrolling and you already get that
you're enrolling the UK and U.S too
smart
um
yeah ultimately when you start thinking
about and that's your awareness of maybe
there is a trending food a trending tea
a trending thing and there's these
different countries now it's also
important to note that he really found
himself at uh a lot of controversy as
well because of just geopolitics the
wrong Flags in his video were on the
wrong countries and uh he'll be fine I'm
sure but nevertheless you know thinking
about those Dynamics but when I think
about key root word research I am
looking for all the way down to I just
saw Arrow again where did I see this uh
the the I think it's a Canadian
chocolate bar that has kind of like the
it's pumped with air bubbles or whatever
and I was like oh man that's like a
throwback because I kind of grew up in
Seattle and on the border of Vancouver
Canada so anyways keyword research using
something like vid IQ or other tools but
but you can see how crazy this gets
because we're only two in topic research
um so many different ways to do topic
research you might be looking at the
topics that um
are in the news uh and and that's just
kind of going broad topics other topics
on the YouTube trending page uh
Community questions and that goes kind
of like audience but Community questions
you ask your community a question but
you also can hack other communities
because some people even watching this
might be like well I don't have an
audience to research yet well what you
do is you go look at your competitors
um and you look at their comment
sections or you look at Reddit
um where they're debating Ramen or
something and you start seeing different
things and then Trend analysis Google
Trends is interesting like is there
something that's spiked on Google Trends
in terms of a certain beverage a certain
food industry research that is where
and and these might not all be relevant
for you we certainly this is why we'll
never run out of video ideas too because
you realize it's just a matter of like
digging deeper but industry research and
other topics could be like looking at an
industry publication or you know and my
friend Jesse Tillman goes to Vegas every
year to the concrete conference he owns
a concrete pouring company and I'm like
how could there be is there that much
innovation in concrete he's like you
have no idea he's like telling me about
it and so there's influencers in the
concrete industry there's and I don't
mean influencers like they've got the
purple Starbucks drink and they're
taking selfies on the streets of
Hollywood Boulevard you know like I'm
talking about like uh people of
influence that if you're in a subculture
in a sub Niche researching your industry
what are the blogs talking about your
industry where you know and then
competitor analysis which would be
looking at going to different channels
who are your top 5 10 15 20 competitors
um and then what are the most popular
videos and topics on their channels one
of our goals is realizing there are
literally a million videos you could
make next there's probably more than
that I mean we live in kind of an
infinite World where there's so many
different food products you could talk
about we want to focus in on that one
percent or the one percent of the one
percent of the very best ideas and then
invest our energy in those topics not
enough creators
um are understanding they think
thumbnails most important or titles most
important or even the content that's
most important but what what supersedes
all of it is actually the topic itself
as you can see it's proven on your
channel that some of your topics
can get a hundred thousand views so even
if the cool thing too is we talked about
this earlier
is even if all we could do is get you to
250 000 views
well now we're at 800 bucks and then if
we could get you to half a million we're
at 1500 and 750 000 we're at two grand
and then a million views at a three
dollar RPM is three thousand dollars and
and then you start realizing I'm
investing this energy I'm putting in the
hustle right now but now how do I want
to reinvest that money what was it I
want to um you know maybe what is my
path to part-time with my current job do
I ever want to let go of that because of
the influence but probably certainly
having the freedom and maybe your own
team and 10K plus a month coming in
maybe that's more attractive to you so
what are your thoughts on what we've
talked about so far
fantastic one of the reasons that I've
been spinning my wheels so much on this
lately is because I'm sitting here being
like
um do I go review another UK candy video
but just it just through the research
thing you just did there already is like
really unlocking a lot of ideas and a
strategy incredibly helpful so thank you
for that
um I do have access to some of the
analytics and data for The Insider food
page in which I'm a host and producer of
do you think it's a wise strategy to
look at how that audience is reacting to
my work and applying that to what I'm
doing on my Channel or is it like
different channels 100 oh yeah it's
that's an advantage and you also don't
necessarily need to have access to the
back end but you do which is cool
um because if I just simply go to their
videos that go to popular
then I might try to see off this like
you
won I don't know how hard is it to get I
mean did you have to go to the UK to do
the UK how did you get the UK I have
been there before the the way that it
works now is I film the show they see
there's called food Wars I shoot we pick
a fast food brand we've done snacks and
candies out of the country since then
but I shoot my stuff in the U.S and then
we have another producer in the UK or
the other country shoots it and then we
edit together so it's like a
side-by-side compare comparison and
since then myself has gone to the UK and
the UK co-host has come to uh America
and we've shot some like out in the
world stuff so we're kind of like slowly
building that universe and therefore my
that's gonna sound so egotistical my
profile online has been growing and
that's another reason to be like if
people are like recognizing me it seems
like Now's the Time to be like well I
should build my own thing you know what
I mean well
next big idea do your own collabs
okay yeah so start start tapping into
like start reaching out to creators of
different sizes and the cool thing is
number one you already you can tap in
and leverage your 4.7 million subscriber
kind of brand and like you said your
profile is growing but also what you're
really looking for it's the Excellence
of the content not necessarily the
influence of the person you're just
looking for somebody who has a maybe a
decent following and a decent level of
quality content that can
you know film and collab and send you
the footage and you shout them out but
you put that on your channel and that's
another way to essentially build those
geopolitical you know Bridges as well
you could you could collaborate with
people all around the world uh this is
going to you know and and we are living
in a world where they can drop box you
the footage you could film with like
we're using stream yard right now it's
like you have local record where it's a
little bit more crispy and then it gives
you each file individually so you can
keep the work for flow sort of simple
but that would be another way to do it
you know you're in a unique situation if
I was you
I would actually want to stay at Insider
as long as possible and keep doing well
and keep honoring that just because it
sounds like they've been good to you
there's a lot of influence there and if
you enjoy it
um that's only going to help and of
course having transparent conversations
if they're totally comfortable with
everything else you're doing and if
you're doing a good job for them and
they're cool with this
like that's just influence so that's a
huge blessing and a huge benefit
um I think too I would
try to you know what is the shortest
path to revenue I try to make more money
which is obvious but like very much more
intentionally with more strategic
planning and better goal setting than
ever before and then I would reinvest
that money into building your own team
while you keep your full-time job and by
your own team I would get an editor as
soon as possible that's gonna buy you an
insane amount of time back
um and I would maybe think about so like
if you could survive on your full-time
income and get to two grand a month I
would take three grand a month take that
three grand and hire like an integrator
admin assistant to help you coordinate
and schedule the collabs and like one
good editor
um are you doing the thumbnails yourself
I am at thumbnails the headlines are I
have been part of the job but I am I'm
not precious about it so you're good at
them so I think it's fine and then off
obviously as you continue to you know
inside of era we have just endless
resources to help that stuff but the
real linchpin move is the editor the
second linchpin move
is the admin assistant and that team of
two
could help you
particularly scale the collabs or stay
organized and you know when people join
VRA it's good for one household or one
business unit so you also realize like
maybe you bring on an admin assistant
in six months and 12 months you put them
through VRA your your license to it and
then they start you start building up
your team and then perhaps in 12 months
um you launch out or maybe over the next
24 months you're still at Insider but
now your Channel's at 100K
um momentum's growing you need you do
have a dedicated designer you've got
another editor but that that I think
would make it more sustainable and then
and then I think eventually maybe you go
part-time so maybe you become like pure
talent but you're like hey can I do one
video kind of reminds me of the
trajectory of Omar Al takori on the
think media team because he was here as
like a W-2 and now he's also launched
out on his own but he's still kind of
one of our uh content creators and he
understands the incredible benefit of
being on the think media platform but we
I also I'm so grateful for him and honor
our relationship and everything he's
invested so he's also launching out and
kind of doing his own stuff and he's
scaled back so now he's doing like one
video a week he used to be doing two he
used to be also doing like leadership
stuff internally but it's sort of scaled
down where I would guess the amount of
time he spends on think media
you know is
20 hours a month or or something like
that or who knows you know but and he
also is leveraged even his own editor
and person that travels and films with
him
um and
Etc so we've worked something out but
the relationship has evolved and I think
that you could relate to that trajectory
over the next couple of years and uh as
your own brand continues to scale any
final questions I can answer
[Music]
um
no
because you've given me a lot to think
about so probably but uh nothing that
comes off the top of my head
well uh I love it Joe I appreciate you
and I do want to I know that with as
busy as you are at work and then with as
busy as you are creating content it is
hard to read or listen or especially
like go through the course material and
actually at this point like you probably
don't have a lack of ideas or actions to
take it's more about implementation but
I do want to encourage you
um inside of like VRA Masters
um we've uploaded a lot of new content
and that the the contents you have there
will without a doubt scale you to a
hundred thousand subscribers and Beyond
and so personally I always just try to
block time on my calendar believing that
lifetime uh leaders are lifetime
Learners and as we continue to learn and
sharpen our skills and level up you're
obviously already super talented and
have all this momentum your future is
super bright but you you already have
the resource so just investing in that
resource the time it takes and blocking
a little time and just some parting
words of encouragement
you know I want to empathize with you
that the feelings of fatigue and
overwhelm and this season of how much
you have on your plate
and juggling it all
you're doing the work Joe I mean this is
this stuff is real and everybody
watching this I think can relate to when
you when you kind of take that
entrepreneurial leap non-entrepreneurs
can't relate to it the pressure the
weight the sometimes like just your mind
spinning or or wanting to quit or give
up or having thoughts go through your
head is like does anyone even care does
anyone even see does anyone even
understand the work I'm putting in the
season you're in right now
is is actually when it'll be the worst
you know today
I you know the the profit
and Scholar
you know Notorious B.I.G had it right
when he said Mo Money Mo Problems you
know it's like I mean I got stressed and
I got problems today but
it's different when I had a full-time
job that was 40 50 hours a week working
at a church and I was trying to do my
side hustle at the same time
man it's hard to get off work and want
to do research or get off work or even
your brain like you gotta hack your
brain you get home and it's easier to
like just kind of want to rest and you
should I mean actually what you should
do when you're tired is rest but when
you got a dream and you got a vision and
you got a goal you're like okay I
probably am dehydrated so let me Crush
like 30 ounces of water go for a walk
um you know listen to something
inspirational and then get myself back
in my audience uh my office at home and
do some research and that's obviously
already what you're doing because you
are publishing content but I just want
to encourage you that a season of
uncommon discipline in a season of
uncommon focus in a season of uncommon
uh time management
is the bridge from the full-time job and
the channel and the not enough money to
the team the enough money the getting
buying some of your sanity back buying
some of your piece back and then it's
still hard but it's a different hard and
so just I want to encourage you not to
quit just to keep going it's inspiring
to see what you're doing and uh and it's
inspiring to our community as well I
know that well thank you I appreciate
that very much and yeah you're right it
feels like a heavy slog that when the
video gets a thousand views and you see
you made 14 cents off of it you're like
what am I what am I doing again but it
really helps to hear that so thank you
very much Sean Joe I appreciate you so
much um thanks so much for jumping on
the coffee
all right all right my friend everyone
yeah thanks take care
what was your aha moment from today's
conversation with Joe I'm going to hit
your questions in just a second but
smash the like button if you are getting
value out of this combo in this show
we're on the think media podcast Channel
um and we're excited that was a fun
convo and you know one of the reasons we
do this is I hope that you're getting
takeaways and nuggets for your own
channel and your own life your own side
business what you're building I also
want to remind you today's coffee
channel is brought to you by free
thinkclass.com if you want to go a
little bit deeper you know one of the
things that is so powerful about YouTube
when you're in the side Hustle season
trying to make a bridge to the
solopreneur season where you're full
time no longer have a job but you're
making enough money to cover all your
bills so now you can at least work 40 50
60 hours just on your channel
um is ranking videos that are connected
to passive income so you have videos
that are making you money every month
when you're not working or you have a
video that's six months old that's still
making money for you you know we talk
about hiring a team
ranked videos are like employees that
you pay once that work for you for weeks
months and years to come for free you
pay them up front well what do you mean
pay them you pay them with your time and
your research and your hustle but if you
have a video that's you made six months
ago that's paying you six months later
that's a really good return on energy
and a return on investment and that's
what our obsession is here at think
media so
freethinkclass.com breaks down
specifically not just how to rank videos
but connect them to passive income
streams and it's an on-demand replay
that's available for the next five days
or something depending on when you're
watching this or the link might take you
somewhere else
um
two years from now in the future if you
happen to be here if you're watching
this in 2025 please leave a comment
below because that would be weird and
I'm really grateful for you
um hello from the past
weird all right I'm sipping coffee what
are you drinking
I see aha moments come in
I need to actually switch my camera
angle to join you over here
Onyx uh coffee today
Onyx is a great coffee company
um and uh
if you ever get into like really good
single origin type of coffee Onyx Coffee
Labs
no affiliate link because they don't
have one or you know I'd be doing it
um is is a really great uh coffee brand
Onyx Coffee if you're not in a really
Niche weird coffee like that no worries
BCAAs I'm gonna mix those up a little
bit earlier a little bit of Crete
creatine with some BCAAs we got H2O in
the house
um and we got a couple aha moments The
Carriage House aha moment reminder to
check Google Trends more regularly
regularly
especially with the holidays coming up
I like it and um
we've got six dance Stars just started
selling my own coffee for our people I
love that
um I just spoke at armed conference with
Evan and Alan didio and they've got a
coffee company in all the the raising
money for sex trafficking and it's
really cool what they're doing so yeah
that's powerful that you've got some
Mission driven coffee there
and uh staying strong and pushing
forward YouTube it could be a slog it's
hard work and that's why I appreciate
you tuning into the show we're here to
support you I encourage you and I want
to thank you for being here let's hit
some of your questions what is the
perfect weekly upload count for a new
channel no such thing
the best thing to do to get success on
YouTube is to upload videos on YouTube
that's gonna be thing one so I would
encourage you to upload videos I would
encourage you to upload as many as you
can whenever you can at the best quality
you're capable of right now
um the perfect upload schedule I want to
encourage you is one that I think has a
rhythm and has consistency to it and has
around a system we don't rise to the
level of our goals we fall to the level
of our systems our life systems you have
a morning routine an evening routine
systems around your eating systems
around your energy so if you also have
systems around your YouTube production
schedule I think that one of the best
ways to be consistent is to pick like a
video a week now a video a week is not a
magic number
there's you could upload one video and
it could get a million views a month for
the next 10 months so that's cool so one
video could produce more than a lot of
other videos we could spin off in that
down that Rabbit Trail what I've learned
though that gives the majority of us
success is it's kind of like how often
should you go to the gym and how hard
should you work out
well as many days as you can so if you
could go to the gym and work out one day
a week your health will improve if you
go go to the gym and work out three days
a week your health will improve now if
you go to the gym
and just like sit on the you know the
bench and look at your phone and not
actually lift up anything well just
because you're at the gym doesn't mean
you're going to get results just because
you upload a video to YouTube doesn't
mean you're gonna get any results so
there's also like the quality of the
work you put in now
my quality of work I put in at the gym
is not very good but it's getting better
because I keep showing up and so as much
as you can but set a routine set a
Content calendar and then people get
weird they're like what if
well what if I'm uploading weekly but I
don't upload on the fifth week because
I'm too I was busy you know it's gonna
destroy my world
no dude it does take a week off but then
just get get back to it so if you're
just jumping on I encourage you to watch
the first part of the training and you
know there's time codes and chapters
which on the coffee with candle show we
do like an upfront like 10 15 20 minute
training and I shared the four month
plan
is a video a week over the next 18 weeks
that's 18 videos
I do that
but Sean I want to upload shorts too
well then upload shorts too but Shawn I
want to do two videos a week then do two
I don't know I don't know okay no sorry
like
you can tell he hasn't been sleeping you
can tell his kids are going crazy all
right Big Valley living at the beginning
of August we released a vlog that we
debated about for two years we have
since monetized but how do you
encourage and engage relevant
advertisers
so great congratulations on one getting
monetized congratulations on
that's at least a thousand subscribers
four thousand hours of watch time
um I think what you do is you reach out
to companies
and
don't take silence as a no take it as
they probably didn't see it
and reach out
multiply your efforts 10 times more than
you think in terms of actually Landing
like an Advertiser or brand deal and
that's I assume I assume what we're
talking about
so if you want to reach
a brand and engage them to advertise in
your Channel
first make sure you have influence and
it sounds like you do you've got some
momentum you've got some influence you
got a good thing going because your
channel is monetized second
make a list of 10 to 30 to 50 companies
you want to work with and put them in a
Excel spreadsheet or a Google
spreadsheet
third
reach out to them across
multiple touch points
so go to their website find their
contact page find out if they have a
marketing department find if they've got
because sometimes it says select the
topic General inquiry a return you know
marketing and PR the some that are
Advanced might say influencer collab or
like YouTube or whatever
try to select the relevant category or
just find their email and email them but
too many people stop short and all they
do is email
research who could possibly work in the
marketing department on LinkedIn follow
them connect with them message them and
see if you could get in touch because
you could search the company name
and like marketing or influencer
find the company on Twitter and x and x
them publicly and send a message so many
Brands I'll go to Asus monitors and I'll
say hey do you ever work with
influencers do you ever work with
content creators I'll put like a link to
an example video or my channel let me
know and they'll DM me back or they'll
follow me back
but to the point you need to 10x your
actions and your efforts
I would then tweet 10 monitor companies
when I knew I wanted to build a home
office and I was hoping maybe I could
get free monitors instead of having to
buy them for like a battle station setup
I was like okay in preparation for that
mind you I had influence already which
was number one and I tweeted 10 monitor
companies three replied I narrowed it
down I've gotten multiple free standing
desks I I messaged multiple standing
desk companies and three replied and I
narrowed it down to the one I wanted to
work with and went back and forth so
email Twitter LinkedIn you're you're
going a lot deeper and one percent of
people do this the good news is that
not putting anybody down but you can
take advantage of the fact that the
majority of people are lazy like the
more majority of people are like I
called once
and it didn't work it's like someone's
saying I can't find a job how many jobs
did you apply to I applied to one okay
bro like great it's how about apply to
10 a day for the next 10 days and so
it's something about multiplying your
actions and your efforts and your energy
what you'll begin to see happen is I
promise you if you find 50 possible
collaboration companies that align with
your Vlog reach out to all 50 across
three or four or five touch points that
on the other side of that some
conversations will start maybe it'll
lead to different collabs different
things different ways and that my final
tip would be then also be open to Biz
Dev Business Development what do I mean
by that it's kind of a way of saying
don't be so
fixed in what it's going to look like
Business Development
wrong camera business development is it
could be free product it could be they
pay you money like a traditional brand
deal it could be they hire you actually
to make them like a ugc ad they hire you
to because you can make Vlogs to
actually integrate it's not your
influence that they're paying for
they're paying for you to make them a
promotional video meaning
they can run it as their own ad or put
it on their own website so they kind of
want you the talent and you the video
production company essentially to make
them an ad so Biz development is not
just like hey advertise on my terms like
what terms could we work out
and then the final tip after the final
tip I don't know what number we're on
and then like number five I think is
um Leverage
every project
to help scale up to bigger projects
leverage every brand deal as a case
study to help you to Future brand deals
once you do one it becomes a portfolio
asset to the next one once you do a few
things these become case studies for
your Media Kit once others see that
you're working with some Brands you then
leverage and say this is what I'm able
to produce for other brands if you want
to demonstrate what you're capable of
doing for a brand and then develop out
your own menu of if you will Services
especially in the early days of like the
crater economy hustle this is the
mentality that you need to win too many
people are like I just can't get like a
brand deal nobody wants to just like
send me a ten thousand dollar check to
like shout them out of my video and I
don't get why I have 2 000 subscribers
and my content is really cool why can't
I have that happen
well okay Jennifer I mean I get it but
the thing is like
if are you willing to work
Jennifer
and are you willing to think outside of
the box
Mike okay these are
fictional people as you know if you've
been on the coffee with candle show so
let me know if any of that helped those
are a few tips uh how well does this
strategy work for different kinds of
channels I have a channel where I talk
about anime and discuss I'm not sure
this would work well you know you might
if you're okay with
um
with doing a video that's still on brand
but that's like maybe a little bit
different you could
put out a video that's about like
you know best books for drawing anime
that might not be right but you could
these I just looked up anime you could
talk about
um
you know best anime deals on Amazon you
know if you go over here and you go
uh anime Amazon
uh products
and you look over here and we see okay
maybe it's maybe it's cosplay type stuff
yeah this is cool maybe it's
um
kind of Funko Pop type of stuff maybe
it's action figures maybe it's merch
we're just talking about a one-off video
Bella you know and
you would know best if your audience is
like that was a weird left turn because
you're like actually I don't know
reviewing things or walking through or
commentary but like it takes it just
takes your own tact
and skill and sensitivity to your brand
to weave it in like why is it you're
talking about it so again
I like doing this by thinking about how
I'm actually integrating my life into my
content I was drinking the coffee pods
so I made a video about it I was using
the green juice so I made a video about
it I buy the books and read the books so
I made a video about it if you you could
in preparation say oh man I'm gonna do a
little haul and you do a haul of best
deals on Amazon or uh discounts on you
know you know and that's just Amazon
there's probably some specific anime
websites with products and and would
actually just expanded my mind as I went
to YouTube and I searched the topic
was
the industry of anime the from action
figures to maybe cosplaying all the
different things there's probably an
incredibly deep well
of opportunity that's why the two
questions were what are people searching
for
and what are people buying
so what are people searching for what
are people buying is there a Netflix for
like anime
um can you is there an affiliate program
for
um
for their streaming service
so I'm looking up anime streaming
services
so Crunchyroll
so could you make a video about
Crunchyroll and does Crunchyroll have an
affiliate program I don't know that's
what you have to look up and then could
you get paid on continuity do you get a
dollar a month or 30 cents a month if
someone signs up through your link is
there a program and if by the way if
there's not an affiliate program as your
brand grows can they set you up with one
could it be a brand deal
and there's
um where you're big enough micro or Nano
influencer where they do set you up with
10 percent
reoccurring
and your own custom link
Biz Dev you you build that out on your
own as you grow and you have the vision
for it
where do I even begin to look for
affiliate programs that match my Niche
if you have time get in a
uh
another question with what your Niche is
how can a faith-based channel take
advantage of affiliate marketing so
knowing that this is a faith-based niche
I can take this one so
um so how could a faith-based channel
take advantage of affiliate marketing I
got to figure out like a consistent way
I like having the window open but you
notice that like the exposure goes up
and down because the light outside is
inconsistent whatever
so how can a faith-based channel take
advantage of affiliate marketing there's
many different
step number one is to identify and ask
yourself what are people buying step
number two is to say what are people
searching for step number three is to
identify the vendors and retailers that
are selling different things that are
relevant for a faith-based market Amazon
books on Amazon pens and highlighters
for your Bible that's on Amazon too
Bibles themselves uh NIV versus NLT
different versions if you're really
Niche you got a Dake out here uh that's
pretty Niche anybody know uh and so
different versions by the way these
little tabby things like what are people
buying okay
um but then you go Logos Bible Software
you could get a really high Commission
on the 500 or a thousand or 1500 level
of that if it's like a digital library
for pastors or students of the word
um you go to Daily Grace Co and you got
pens and highlighters and mugs Christian
book distributors or these different
Christian bookstores so you gotta do
your research and your reconnaissance
but the opportunities are endless you
then look you can promote another
influencers product and what I mean is
like
you take somebody that has a Bible study
course
40 bucks 50 bucks and they give you 50
commission so you get 25 every
transaction maybe and that this is
encouraging because you're also like you
know I have a channel encouraging people
but I'm not ready to like make a course
on like how to study the Bible I myself
am kind of a beginner that's why what
you ultimately can be as a
kind of a reporter or a knowledge broker
you could even interview different
authors or course creators that have
uh you know
a doctorate in Divinity and have a
degree and whatever you know that our
theology experts you just bring them on
your show and you link to their book and
their educational materials and you make
money as an affiliate a lot of ideas we
just shared inside of there but you
could see that
um I want to encourage you all the
opportunities are endless
um they really are and in every Niche
it's just a matter of digging getting
educated and and you know we have a
whole process of course inside of our
deeper uh training video ranking Academy
to help you become to really learn a new
set of skills and develop a whole new
set of lenses for life to see
opportunities to position your content
and to create videos that earn you
passive income while also helping people
because again if you connect somebody I
mean think about the purpose drivenness
of somebody that doesn't understand the
Bible you're not like fully ready to
like you can kind of encourage them but
you can't like really break it down you
could be a knowledge broker meaning you
bring on somebody that can really unpack
that for them and interview them using
something like stream yard and then link
to their materials in the description
that person reaches more people with
their stuff you get to your financial
goals faster the person that's seeking
to literally get closer to God and
understand the Bible better gets great
materials the the economy is stimulated
it's such a
win-win-win-win-win and so
I hope that's helpful and again I know
you got a million questions we got to
land the plane here in a second but
that's why your next step would be to go
to free think class because free
thinkclass.com I break down
um more tactically how to set this up
because obviously the videos actually
have to get views and you want to make
sure that it's set up properly and I
talk about a lot of nuances that we
don't have time to cover here Michael
says I'm sure I'm just
my content needs to be improved but how
do I get more views and subscribers I've
been posting for five weeks now and I
have hardly anything going what is the
best time and day to post
so Michael without analyzing your videos
it's hard to say exactly what you should
do
uh yes improve your content but I love
this question and I've got some advice
for you Michael you've been posting for
five weeks
and uh I need you to relax I need you to
take a deep breath and I need you to
summon a whole new level of Courage
but I'm going to share the p word and I
hate to say it
it's patience
patience
you've been posting for five
weeks and I get it self-doubt floods in
is this even work worth it why is this
not working yet bro
join me on coffee with candle in five
years and if it still hasn't really
gotten some traction and you're
continuously improving well then we need
to have a deep conversation
and I know it might be coming off a
little harsh Michael but I know all of
us need to hear this like too many of us
are like I uploaded six videos why am I
not a global Superstar why does Taylor
Swift sell more tickets to our events
than I have subscribers
Taylor's been in the game for a little
while she's also a unicorn obviously but
how long how long has Taylor Swift
been singing
uh since 14
since 2005
and so her self-titled album was 2006.
so we're talking about 17 years and if
you just had one percent of that success
like people just we got to have patience
but this brings me to a very important
announcement that I've totally forgot
today is think media's birthday and
think media turned
13 today this is the think media podcast
Channel which is like three
think media turned 13 years old today
Michael 13 years old you're talking to
me in five weeks what are you even
saying man
bro like I get it and I'm here to help
and watch our videos and keep improving
your content
but 13 years and I've been doing YouTube
for 16 years video for 20. we gotta up
this patience game so if you go back
here is the first ever video on think
media it's August 23rd 2010 and
here's young Sean uh posted a video and
this was 13 years ago happy birthday
think media today at this exact moment
thanks for joining me in in my Michael
thanks for inspiring the question but
let's go look at uh the trajectory of
growth in our lifetime YouTube Analytics
because I think one of the important
things to see
um is just how long things can take and
how long things can feel flat before
they break out
and so if we go back to like Day Zero
and day one there it is
one View
[Laughter]
how many views did you get one
I mean do you get a subscriber no I got
a view
and look how flat things were 2010 2011
2012 2013 2014. now here's the good news
here at think media we're here to help
you get there a lot faster because
obviously I made a lot of mistakes and
this was also I had a side hustle at a
full-time job and I also did too many
channels like everything this is why
we're on a mission to help a million
purpose-driven people create a full-time
living doing what they love will make a
difference in the world with YouTube is
you get to learn from my mistakes and
having four channels when you're getting
like one view is a horrible idea you
need to focus your energy so my energy
was divided I also had a full-time job I
I there's tons of dumb stuff I was doing
and that's why being subscribed to this
channel is helpful but notice this that
it wasn't until like 20
15. now we're at like two thousand three
thousand views a day which is pretty
cool
but then look how things start going up
and now 2016 50 000 views a day now
we're at 2020 150 000 views a day
a couple crazy spikes where we had like
a couple viral videos and now you see
the steadiness of just 153
000 views a day and fast forward to this
at 414 000 and we're at kind of like a
new level and now we're usually over 200
000 views a day
but friends you're looking at a 13 year
spread
and Michael I'm sending you massive love
but bro you just asked me like why is
this not working after five weeks
like
what
five weeks
dude nothing works after five weeks and
a lot of people overestimate even how
much they think they can accomplish in
five years
like there's something about
steady consistency in the same direction
over time
learning and leveling up as you go
and without opening your channel of
course we could get into tactics but I
think the biggest
pill you need to swallow
is your patience pill
coffee with candle every morning you
take your vitamins
more important than vitamin C more to
more important than vitamin D plus k
is vitamin P
ensions
Focus follow one course until successful
patience okay
are we having fun I gotta be fired up
and happy birthday think media uh thank
you so much
um and uh
the transformation does not look like 13
years I appreciate it yeah it all starts
with one one view day one I got a view
and that was me you know you click on
your own video like hey Mom I started a
channel uh that's a good one too oh that
you gotta have the two P's take your
patience pill and pray
and then persevere
and then stay positive and tap into your
purpose
and then
Embrace persistence and then watch from
the Philippines
that's the key
um I appreciate you AO and Michael if
you're here still here I'm saying
nothing but love and respect but but
dude five weeks
literally put like set a reminder on
your phone because let me hit you with
another piece of a hard pill to swallow
the reason so many people fail or so
many people don't break through is they
just give up they get to like week 10
and they're like I guess this doesn't
work they get to year one and a half and
they're like apparently this isn't gonna
work look at the trajectory
let me ask you this what if I gave up
here what if I gave up here what if I
gave up here what if I gave up here like
if I could just see that five years into
it if I could see that 10 years into it
if I could see that 13 years and then if
I kept getting smarter and I kept
also leveling up my skills I mean I by
the way I hadn't really seen this but
um
so I've never actually revealed the
lifetime earnings of think media
but right now we're at one million six
hundred and eighty nine thousand nine
hundred and twenty four dollars and
seventy one cents that's on our 13th
birthday how much the one channel is
earned but the other key to know is that
my business think media has earned
20 30 million dollars or something
forgive me for not knowing the exact
number over that time most of it on the
back end I mean that's obviously the key
you're like wait in year one no year one
was like 10 bucks you know but fast
forward and so having multiple streams
of Revenue AdSense just becomes the tip
of the iceberg and so most people though
they won't make it past month six or
year three or the challenges that come
even when you're successful at your
seven and a half this takes work friends
and it is hard work and it does take
patience
um but I encourage you patience prayer
and persistence
um the three p's okay
listen we gotta land the plane we're an
hour and 15 in I've got a few more
minutes I'll get to as many questions as
I can maybe we'll try to do a lightning
round impossible though
because I can't go lightning it's got to
be doesn't have to be long to be lethal
is what
Benny Perez would say um Julian hi I'm
launching my YouTube channel I'm
struggling about the mixed topics of
digital photography tools and
Entrepreneurship targeting researchers
what's your opinion
and type of name for the channel
okay so any type of name well I think
your first and last name is great
because apart from naming it a brand
like think media just name it your name
um so that's fine
and
I think Julian the big thing here is
just to really get clear about not
necessarily mixing
because just because you want to do
digital photography productivity tools
well actually if you want to do digital
productivity tools for entrepreneurs
entrepreneurs do want to be productive
so you're already good that's a good mix
for I read it at digital photography
tools like so if you're doing like a
like a photo editing Channel
I wouldn't mix it with entrepreneurship
I would just become like the number one
but that's not what you're saying so I
think you're already on the right track
it's
the two questions you want to ask
are who is your channel for and what
problem does it solve and so if it's
over art if it's like helping
entrepreneurs become more productive
that's a great vision there's your
answer
it could be software it could be tools
it could be mindsets it could be
interviews helping entrepreneurs
with time management and productivity
Circle scuba Sean thought
it's on talking blogs to your niche
thoughts on taking blogs in your Niche
they're trending recent posts and making
videos of the content it's one of my
it's one of the best things you could do
you've you've struck on a golden idea
that 99 of creators Miss
there's so much written content that
is already proven because it ranks
and you're not going to copy it
but you're going to be inspired by it
and realize they've already done a lot
of heavy lifting so you're going to spin
it make it your own add your own content
and so yeah if you were going to make a
productivity video and you Google
productivity tips and see a life
uh hacker you know
which is a popular website and then you
get inspired even by the headline and
the title 100 because also some people
are skilled in
written word but you have the capability
of making videos
and then you also already though have
some level of proof of concept depending
on how well the blog post performed or
to your point if they've highlighted a
trend you also could react to it so I
see some people say like a lot of
financial shows will say like
you know today we're going to look at
the five Financial trends that are
happening with Millennials this article
comes from CNBC
Ken Coleman does that Grant Cardone does
that so you're leveraging OPC other
people's content you're leveraging an
article you're leveraging a Blog and
you're just putting it into video format
what do you guys think about Facebook
reels they're hot they're not as hot as
they were there was the there was a
moment in our lives
that year ago year and a half ago where
my gosh we went through a season we had
a couple hit like 29 million 20 million
19 million 18 million
um and I like that they're okay now
everything's great whatever vertical
video what do I think about vertical
video Ricardo I think it's awesome
because when you have a vertical video
asset you could upload it as a Facebook
reel Instagram reel Tick Tock and a
YouTube short and I think that's smart I
think what I've noticed is that too many
people
get addicted to dopamine
and they have some breakout videos like
we did
and we get 10 million 20 million 500 000
on Facebook reels and then you fast
forward to today and
we don't
and the Brain drugs crash is so severe
that people go what is the meaning of
life
why was I even born My Views are down
I'm not getting subscribers
the algorithm is against me
what's even the point
that's you got to relate to those
emotions you got to know that's what you
fix so I mean you know
4 18 818 934 1500 2800 3500 these are my
Facebook reels
um 2.7 3.6
3.3 12 000.
um but this is 344 347
000.
so this is what if you didn't understand
this about me and maybe why
I've been able to compound and create
consistent success over time is because
of developing an attribute called
resilience
one of the most important skill sets
and mindsets
that creators need in today's world is
resilience
I used to think it just meant like not
quitting and persevering and that's not
what it means resilience means how
quickly do you get back to Baseline
so if you have a discouraging day a
discouraging week and you feel really
down discouraged and depressed how
quickly do you bounce back to just
neutral Baseline
but even more important if you have an
incredible day an incredible week an
incredible month all my reels are going
viral 10 million views 500 000 views 30
million views
whoa dopamine like you're just going
crazy
how quickly do you get back to Baseline
and the two traps that content creators
fall in as they fall in this discouraged
depressed
down
ditch or they fall into this
delusional
success
yesterday I was killing it today things
have changed and I'm also
now either not putting in the work maybe
things are even still going good so I
stopped putting in the work because I'm
writing off of yesterday's virality
which means
you have already you got to start
hearing the drums and the Dirge of
defeat because if you stop putting in
the work because you're on a high then
the fruit of sowing those seeds means
that weeks or months ahead why did
everything stop because you let it go to
your head
so resilience is actually not letting
the down days or the the discouragement
keep you down but it's how fast can you
bounce back or the celebrations in the
wind keep you delusional prideful let
your ego get inflated you stop putting
in the work you stop staying paranoid
and analyzing the landscape you stop
like looking innovating and adapting and
improving and you also get back to
Baseline
so that's my point it's too many people
are like oh if it wasn't what it once
was and I'm like I'm a small town kid
College Dropout dude give me 418 views
I'm gonna be happy about that give me 4
500 I'll be happy about that give me a
down week I'm gonna be happy about that
give me an up week I'm going to be happy
about that I'm just going to keep doing
the work I'm not going to judge My Life
by The Harvest I'm reaping I'm going to
judge My Life by the seeds that I'm
sowing and I just know that if I keep
planting seeds uploads of vertical video
YouTube shorts reels uploads of
long-form video some videos do better
others don't do video as well if you
work a system I'm just going to keep
planting seeds and following the system
and then I have created
literally like a flywheel of compounding
success in the highs and the lows some
months are much higher and they're
shockingly high some much are much lower
but the reason it's Unstoppable is
because I don't let the highs or the
lows stop me
resilience my friends
we have to develop resilience
number one skill set probably one of the
number one mindsets content creators
need
is resilience smash like if you're uh
getting some value out of today's
conversation and um
how what's your rebellions on a scale
from one to ten what's your resilience
level
if you have a high do you do you stop
putting in the work and spend all the
money and go celebrate if you get
discouraged is it hard to get back to it
you know it's kind of like if you have
if you're really discouraged I heard one
coach say hey you got five minutes
yeah hey you got five minutes complain
curse cry but then bounce back and get
back to work
um you have a really big win hey
celebrate it take it celebrate tonight
schedule a dinner get your family go out
to dinner great get up next morning 5
a.m get back to work why did Kobe may
you rest in power get back to the gym
after winning championships resilience
the Mamba mentality he got back in the
gym whether it was a high or a low
hey Gabby good to see you
great good to see you and uh Taylor yeah
my coach used to say that I'm knocked
down cool you got five minutes hey come
cry complain whatever but then get back
get back at it I was reading uh this
book on uh the hard thing about hard
things and there's this chapter called
nobody cares and sometimes we can become
so so self-loathing and this guy was
talking about a coach in his life and he
was like oh my God a guy that's drawn at
our company and I'm employees are
fighting and our revenue's down and we
might go out of business and oh my man
and it's all true
and you know what this guy told him he
goes bro nobody cares run your company
nobody cares
and that might seem harsh you might be
like my wife cares well sure I mean okay
but the mentality is is like if you're
out here looking for external
affirmation
it's like just suck it up buttercup and
get back to work that's resilience and
you care and you could do this and of
course if you're a person of faith and
you've got a relationship with God then
you also have this Inner Strength where
you know that God cares even when you're
misunderstood and other people don't
understand you
it's like you've got an inner fire like
Christ uh Paul said that I strive with
all of Christ's energy I'm compelled by
the love of God so it's like an inner
fire David strengthened himself in the
Lord so of course that's I think the
ultimate because a lot of times even
your spouse or your friends or your
family will misunderstand you they might
even try to tear you down not Build You
Up can you be resilient through that can
you be resilient when everyone's
supporting you and cheering you on can
you be resilient when you actually feel
like internally your spouse is tearing
you down internally your spouse is not
encouraging you internally the people in
your world your parents or your friends
are speaking death over you can you
still keep going you actually can
but it's a mental toughness and a
resilience that's got to be built
can we smash like
I think that uh I want to say a few
things as we land the plane so many
great questions are coming in and I want
to encourage you make sure you're
subscribe to this channel because we do
schedule coffee with candles usually
about a day in advance and therefore you
can uh you know turn on notifications
save the stream so you can get here as
early as possible to get your question
in and we always get to as many as we
can I also want to say that your next
step would definitely be if you're
wanting more of this kind of content and
specifically Deep dive in our topic of
today of how to make four
thousand dollars in the next four months
go to free thinkclass.com for some
tactics on that and then by the way you
know uh at the end of that I talk about
our program video ranking Academy so I
mean a full transparency what's the
secret that Sean is trying to do I have
an online course and Community we have a
private group it's it's like the number
one YouTube course people actually love
it we have like the best guarantee in
the whole industry and all this kind of
stuff but like whether that's right for
you or not no worries like this class is
free and I promise you it'll be worth
your time it will not be a waste of your
time to go to free thinkclass.com check
out the training grab a notebook grab a
journal and really engage with it and
then if you ever want to be a part of
what's called video record Academy then
you can learn a little bit more about
that because we do have a limited
special that's happening and you'll
learn about that at the end of the class
Link in the description as well pin
comment time codes chapters
um and all of that kind of stuff as well
I'm gonna send you love respect
gratitude I want to send you cheers and
I want to encourage you you keep going
don't quit build your resilience my name
is Sean Cannell rhymes with YouTube
channel this has been the coffee with
Channel show and I can't wait to see you
in a future